On November 20, 2022, news broke
that actor and martial artist Jason
David Frank died at 49 years old. While
Frank's acting career spanned decades,
his best-known work was playing the Green and
White Rangers in the original "Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers" TV series. News of Frank's
death hit fans hard, given the important
part he played in the franchise's early
popularity and subsequent development.
Frank's life even mirrored that of the Green
Ranger, in that both he and his most well-known
character ended up succeeding in unlikely ways. In
"Power Rangers" canon, the Green Ranger starts off
as a villain, before overcoming his evil influence
and eventually leading the Power Rangers team.
Frank, meanwhile, initially signed on for
just 10 episodes of "Power Rangers," but
ultimately became so popular he stuck
around not just for the balance of the
original "Power Rangers" show but for a number of
subsequent incarnations of "Power Rangers" also.
Of course, Frank booked the Green Ranger role
in the first place at least partially on the
strength of his martial arts abilities. In
fact, Frank's martial arts expertise nearly
landed him in a fight with noted action movie star
Jean-Claude Van Damme on two separate occasions.
"I don't want to hurt you."
"Me? You don't want to hurt Hank?"
In November 2017, combat sports blog
FloCombat published a history of the
contentious relationship between Frank and
Van Damme, including some direct quotes from
Frank himself explaining how their dynamic
twice nearly erupted into full-on fights.
First, Frank met Van Damme, who he had
idolized, at a "Power Rangers" event in
1995. Frank found Van Damme rude, and in 2010
issued a challenge to fight Van Damme in an
organized mixed martial arts match. This first
possible fight, however, never came to fruition.
Then, backstage at a Comic Con
event in 2017, after both actors
finished scheduled appearances, Van Damme
approached Frank alongside his entourage,
seemingly looking to provoke the Green Ranger
into hitting him. Frank told FloCombat,
Shortly after that, Comic Con
security separated the two men.
A Daily Mail piece about this incident notes
that Frank also challenged Herschel Walker and
pro wrestler CM Punk to fight him as well.
Whereas nothing came of these challenges,
however, his beef with Van Damme
culminated in a face-off seven years
later that nearly blew up into a backstage brawl.
According to Frank's account, the aggressor
in the situation was Van Damme. Frank,
meanwhile, had previously suggested the two
compete in a sanctioned MMA competition.
Despite the nature of this experience, Frank
maintained that he held no ill will toward Van
Damme in its aftermath. In a Facebook post
shortly after news of the incident broke,
for example, Frank encouraged fans of Van
Damme's films to continue to appreciate
his body of work without letting the
near-fight influence their opinion.
Frank also discussed their combative history
during a Q&A at a 2021 Comic Con event. A
fan asked Frank if he's still interested in an
organized bout with Van Damme. Frank responded
that, while he's game, his only interest in
the fight would be to raise money for charity,
given that he holds no ill will
toward Van Damme personally.
While Frank's disappointment with Van Damme as
an individual dated back to 1995, the "Power
Rangers" star was adamant about separating
the artist from his art in his final years.